it was like summertime you know we
almost hit 80 degrees yesterday monica
and we're going to move that up about
another 10 degrees by
easter weekend that means it is going to
be extra warm yeah i was waiting in line
we went out to get our second
coven shots at cashman on saturday it
was a little bit like disneyland waiting
in line
outside people were like it is warm out
here
i was like yeah that's another 10 15
degrees standing in the sunshine but it
was beautiful it really was
and a big shout out to all the folks out
there at
all of those uh vaccination sites who
are
working and helping get people
vaccinated so a lot of folks were moving
through that site on saturday
mid 50s out there with clear skies this
morning 21 is the dew point
and that means the air is staying really
dry 6 31 the sunrise
7 p.m the sunset days are getting
naturally longer
all right so we're going to be warmer
today we're going to move it into the
80s
so if you thought the 70s felt warm
today's going to feel even warmer breezy
to gusty winds tonight tomorrow that
those north winds behind that cold front
going to drop us down to 70
then we're going to shoot up to near
record highs
easter weekend we do have wind
advisories out at the river and along
the lake that go into effect
overnight tonight to 10 o'clock tomorrow
because those winds that's 10 p.m
those winds behind this cold front are
going to be downright gusty and strong
it opens the door for a cool down too
i'll show you in the eight day forecast
how the temps will change
big showers thunderstorms even tornadoes
through the eastern sections of the
country over the weekend four people
died
those twisters were big and so was the
rain there was a lot of flooding around
tennessee
nashville had some flooding which
actually was flash flooding and
displaced people
about 250 people had to be rescued and
put in shelters
83 for today with good sunshine those
southwest winds will keep increasing
tonight
and by tomorrow those north winds behind
that cold front
are going to get downright gusty we'll
drop from 83 to
70 tomorrow but look how we shoot right
back to the 80s to start off april
near 90 degrees on saturday
easter sunday not a lot cooler so watch
out for those chocolate easter eggs
wherever the easter bunny bunny puts
them should be in the shade
and back to 70s next week all right
let's get to the roads
at 6 47. nate might be better to hide
him in the fridge
that's a great idea